c'est l'avenir fabien elle commence
maintenant ou fatigue
ça lui loïc comment ça va les [ __ ]
légende s'appelle entend passer à
l'écran c'est le loïc 2.0
ni jeune milieu ouais ouais c'est vrai
la paix me françois civil mais
schofield voix c'est plutôt peintre
regarde ma vie là actuellement pendant
qu'on parle on voit des jolis plans très
stylé de ces deux casse-tête si
les plus stylées
[Applaudissements]
ppt gifler salut du cul
regarde salue aujourd'hui vous l'avez
compris on va pas faire un casse tête
mais deux casse tête 2-2 chez constantin
je commence à avoir une petite
collection de chez constantin cela
provient de chez d'insolubles le casse
tête je le mettrais en lien dans la
description ils ont des difficultés
trois sur cinq alors je me suis on va
faire une vidéo avec moins certaine mais
avant de commencer sachez que cette
vidéo est sponsorisé par monster.fr
[Musique]
et pourquoi monster.fr tout simplement
parce que trouver un emploi c'est aussi
un casse tête mais grâce à leur site et
à leurs applications monster essayer de
s'adapter à vos besoins et de vous
accompagner dans vos recherches en fait
monster met à votre disposition sur leur
site et leurs apps des outils
qualitative pour rendre votre
candidature encore plus pertinente et il
vous envoie des notifications
personnalisées dès qu'une offre qui vous
correspond et mis en ligne par une
entreprise son app permet de postuler
avec un simple swype est aussi dessus
vous allez trouver des articles avec les
derniers conseils pour vous orienter
monster vous accompagne dans votre
recherche d'emploi mais aussi tout au
long de votre carrière avec des infos
exclusives comme par exemple très
intéressant des baromètres sur les
salaires selon votre fonction ça c'est
quand même top parce que moi
personnellement j'ai personne pour
m'aider pour les casse tête il ya bien
loïc mais health une aide
l'appli rend très fluide vos
candidatures aux offres que monster vous
dépose directement dans le creux de
votre main bref si vous êtes
actuellement à la recherche d'un emploi
monster peut vous rendre la tâche plus
facile donc n'hésitez pas à vous créer
un compte à télécharger l'appli le lien
est évidemment dans la description
revenons maintenant au casse tête de ma
life à savoir les casse-têtes de
constantin on en fait beaucoup d
constantin mais en même temps il est
tellement prolifique donc il ya celui ci
difficulté 3 sur 5 mais hubert de
chalets un solide mahdi en vrai il est
pour les confirmés mais si tu as
l'habitude de faire des casse tête une
voix le pt vite et celui ci il m'a dit
qu'il est très marrant c'est une
tirelire alors c'est une tirelire duquel
faut enlever la pièce mais on est bien
d'accord que la pièce avait pas très
très difficile à enlever un but sur ce
plan là il suffit de faire ça et elle
tombe là en vrai le but est de savoir
ouvrir la boite c'est ça qui paraît plus
compliqué donc je commençais par
celui-là alors celui ci c'est la boîte
d'allumettes
donc déjà on a deux pivots ici mais on
n'a pas de rainures centrale donc il ne
va pas s'ouvrir comme ça évidemment donc
ça ça peut être le fond qui s'ouvre
ça quand même peu de chances que ce soit
c'est parti là et en vrai c'est
clairement cette partie là qui devrait
s'ouvrir on a deux vis ici là on a rien
à appuyer on a un trou là un trou là est
ce que c'est des vrais trucs aux défauts
truc non c'est des vrais d'accord ça ne
dévisse pas là on a les deux mêmes trous
que de l'autre côté ces deux trous là on
les a ici et là pourtant de l'autre côté
donc là on est clairement intéressé par
ce qui est licite clairement quelque
chose qui bloque il ya de fortes chances
que ce soit ce vice ce que je peux le
dévissé ce truc
oui très facilement plus
dévissage effectué je pensais pas je
pensais que c'était cette partie là
qu'elle est ce débit c'est pas celle ci
mais peu importe donc là je leur vie
c'est pourquoi de perles ok là on a
dévissé de 12,1
évidemment ça ne s'ouvre pas parce que
si ce soir reçoit beaucoup trop facile
aurait alors qu'est ce qui bloque
là j'ai aussi cette surface là que vous
pouvez voir à l'avancé un petit peu
c'est un accueil assez bien sûr grand
rectangle et il ya cette bande là en
dessous peut-être je vois un truc dans
les trous non pas du tout je peux
comprendre où est ce que ça bloque vous
savez les casse-têtes si on arrive à les
visualiser en 3d dans nos têtes on ne
peut imaginer ce qui bloque et du coup
essayer de travailler dessus donc là
c'est renversant ça ça peut rentrer
dedans
olalala hockey de ce côté là j'ai une
petite résistance mais de ce côté là
j'ai un truc très très souple quand
j'appuie su alors à ce que si j'appuie
et je fais ça est-ce que ça s'ouvre à la
dommage je pensais que c'était possible
est ce que comme comme serrure peut-être
est-ce qu'en faisant ça je boxe possible
de traiter roma
c'est un principe mais il y en a pas
tellement de choix parce que voir si ça
va dedans
que ça passe là ça danse trop hein pas
du tout
et si je fais les deux trucs en même
temps comme si je fais des trucs en même
temps jerry manuel jory de
dès demain prise d'appui sur les deux
oui non oui on attend ça a bien avancé
là quand même
parce qu'on a bien fait re voir deux
gars se fait à
hesmond on dirait les figurines de koh
lanta
ohé ohé ah ok effectivement si t'as pas
l'habitude des castes et tu peux te
faire avoir parce que tous pas appuyer
en gros là ce qu'on faisait c'était que
par l'extérieur on appuyé sur ses deux
petits bois comme ça qu'ils étaient les
deux bouts de bois qu'il hockey 12
secret ici parce que ça c'était ça et ça
c'était en boîte et dans ça et ça et du
coup en appuyant dessus ça les a
désemboîté le temps qu'on invente donc
vous allez faire d'une main et avancer
très stylé très agréable mais
effectivement noté 3 sur 5 en difficulté
sera je ne mettrai pas en 3 sur 5 le
mettrai plus quand même un 2 sur son
après c'est sympa aussi un des
casse-tête agréable qui ce qui sonne
locke facilement ça me fait penser j'ai
lu des commentaires il serait moi je
regarde plus les vidéos il ya que des
casse tête alors c'est assez marrant
parce que ça tranche énormément avec
ceux qui disent n'y a pas assez de
castet sur la chaîne est on est on a
regardé en taudis vidéo en général il ya
deux casse-tête que c'est à peu près 20%
de la chaîne entre 10 et 20% de la
chaîne c'est pas non plus une en quoi tu
vois là on est sur une préparation
depuis six ou sept mois d'un énorme
casse-tête on va passer la barre des 30
numéros sur ce cas-ci thaçi pièce unique
ça va être une d'agréer d'où les
sponsors comme on sert à ça sert à
financer les cabinets curieuse les les
matières grises la fiction que vous avez
vu le documentaire de la chouette d'or
les gros casse-tête il faut bien que les
fonds il rentre à un moment donné quoi
tu écoutes alors nous avons nous à font
assassiner le premier cas si tu veux et
essayer de nous rien fait du tout le
fait je vous reviens tout de suite ici
par ici je vous laisse avec loïc pour
voir que même temps tu mets moi je
regarde cette fougue en scène d'avoir un
micro un mais je pense qu'ils voulaient
fabien un gros problème avec les micros
d'exhumer un micro hf on dirait genre un
petit un petit chien que tu veux emmener
au aubin ou un petit chalet la
casse tête casse-tête casse tête ça
s'ouvre comment je pense que c'est un
déplacement unilatérale donc ça y'a pas
de problème ça ça fait ça bon toujours
là dessus bien entendu jusqu'il ya un
doute qui bouge phase d'exploration on
connaît le récit cette offre sa
fiche non
je pense que ça sa soupe comme ça
clairement si tu réussis ça serait le
mari le kart like donc lâché ouais c'est
vrai ouais je me vois une photo ouais
donc une photo bien sûr mais douchez 3 3
avec la réalité ce live est installé à
c'est parce que tu m'as dit mme alifa
vont avoir une photo moi je commente une
photo il ya pas de soucis être tué donc
je crois avoir compris comment ça
s'ouvre donc ça c'est une bonne chose
maintenant la question est quel est le
by pass
le nouveau terme de nouveaux modes
master class de loïc ça ne m'étonnerait
grandement crème airs de glisse et ce
tous les dimanches je publiais matin
c'était la tienne du coup taster classe
ça marche puisque les fratries son
autorité d'ailleurs si à jour trois
frères et deux soeurs ont d'une fratrie
à [ __ ] ah ouais j'ai compris comment
elles s'ouvraient après je dois aller
jusqu à ce qu elle souvent à son arrivée
au conseil de la santé
six mois j'ai compris comment on pouvait
guérir ducobu
non maintenant j'ai compris comment des
fauves ans j'ai compris j'ai compris
comment vous avez autant de laval le
dire maintenant mais ça pourrait pas
être un bail ce que j'essaie d'ouvrir sa
et que mon doigt mais si ça passe pas ça
passe pas salah a ça voudrait dire que
[ __ ] je m'en doutais
[Rires]
c'est à aimanter
puis sur quelque chose à te remettre ça
là dedans d'exactement hausse était en
fête annonce était là au
japon il le cas c'est un ah
ça fait ça maintenant mais non mais non
rien en europe
aux
abymes casse-tête résolu hop ça je
voulais saisir je vous le fais gagner
sur mon instagram qui s'affiche ici pas
bio ica incroyable on avoue d'entre
elles mêmes
alors passant à la suite donc j'ai
retiré la pièce on pourrait dire qu'elle
serait très haut lui mais vraiment ce
serait beaucoup trop facile il faut
ouvrir la boite a priori qui va s'ouvrir
comme ça plus
ici un petit trou
là il ya une grosse faim tu attends je
discute se joue 6,6 en extrait l'audio
si on tire on extrait l'audio c'est
chelou donc là je disais il ya un petit
trou là une grosse fentes et derrière il
n'y a rien de spécial assis là il ya
encore un trou et là il ya un
emplacement qui permettrait de mettre la
pièce là
c'est ce qu'il est ça permettrait de
déboulonner ça pas tellement c'est ce
que la pièce permet de dévisser pas
tellement non plus parce que cette forme
là indique quelque chose je sais
vraiment pas par quoi commencer on va
faire l'exploration complète vous
connaissez ça ça ça c'est pouvant c'est
très frustrant des casse tête où t'as
rien qui bouge darien qui se déguise tu
sais pas par quoi tu peux commencer ça
et tu vois qu'il ya des trucs chelous ça
c'est un truc chelou ça peut être aussi
en fait c'est comme dans un tour de
magie il n'y a jamais rien pour rien je
n'arrive même pas à me dire comment elle
va s'ouvrir c'est un délire
ah ah ah ah ah
ça ça se dévissent
est ce qu'il ya une raison à ça
je crois que des vis un truc qui vaut
pas dévisser je crois que c'est un
hasard si j'ai plus de lévis et pas
c'est pas logique parce que à tort je
pense qu'il se dévissent tout si je si
je force un peu parce qu'en fait là
quand j'ai dévissé j'ai senti tout boîte
partout qui se relâcher ça m'a l'air
d'être plus quand même quelque chose de
tension que quelque chose a dévissé
absolument savoir si je peux davis est
celui dans un souci je peut dévisser sud
en dessous c'est pas normal je peut
dévisser suivent ensuite donc c'est pas
normal
ce qu'avec la nuit là-bas ok alors le
fond j'essaie de vous décrire le fond le
fond de la boîte là se font là et c'est
pour ça qu'il ya la petite vitre c'est
pour qu'on puisse voir au fond au lieu
d'être le fond de boîte au lieu d'être
comme ça voyez comme ça en fait au fond
dites vous qu'il ya comme une marche
comme ça et que sur cette marche il ya
des clés qui sont collés peut-être que
je peux les décoller avec la pièce genre
en 2d
donc pas du tout comment elles peuvent
tenir avec un aimant
au quai provost femme avec un aimant ça
a décollé les clés qu était dans le fond
et qu'on les reconnaît entre éleveurs
il ya deux petites clés je sais pas si
vous les voyez bien je le fais un petit
zoom loïc g2 clé ça se voit mais du coup
si je les mets dans la serrure comme ça
va être le plus classique le plus
logique que cherche or s'il ya une
résistance quelque part à quelque chose
a priori rien et je le vois
littéralement sortir par le trou ici
donc je vois bien quel toujours un des
spéciales on a ce trou là aussi je vais
voir ressortir aussi par là donc 90
[Musique]
à
voici ce que j'ai découvert quand j'ai
mis la pièce parallèle à la paroisse
donc la pièce à l'ailé droite comme ça
et que je l'ait approché du trou j'ai vu
que je pouvais appuyé sur la pièce avec
ma clé en fait la pièce elle comble
exactement cette largeur là et donc si
j'appuie un peu avec la pièce la clé sur
la pièce regardez ce qui se passe en
dessous
sa bouche et si j'appuie à fond j'ai pas
encore essayé parce que la demande est
de vous avoir est-ce que ça sans elle ou
pas [ __ ] je pense que oui je pense que
c'est ça et que là ça va se déboîter que
ça doit tenir avec des aimants un truc
comme ça oui oui
et ses lives
à l'été génial c'est vraiment l'une des
meilleures tirelire casse tête que j'ai
eu donc en gros là vous voyez vraiment
l'intérieur ça c'est la petite marche
dont je vous parlais essayer de bien à
filmer voilà comme ça là vous la voyez
bien sûr cette caméra là celle du co ok
les clés du coup agité alors dans quand
c'était comme ça je voyais ça moi d'être
posée comme ça
elle était posée là
et du coup elle était retenue par les
aimants à l'intérieur c'est pour ça que
je les ai pas eu le départ et elles sont
bien accrochés parce que la pièce les a
pas fait tomber un moment donné jusqu'au
avec la pièce et du coup ce le haut ne
bouge pas du tout ça c'est pas du tout
ouvrables ce trou là cette serrure elle
sert à rien juste à nous brainfuck avec
la clé nantes reste il est très malin
très joli très agréable ça c'est un
super cadeau à faire et que je refasse
sa teinte j'aurais jamais dit que ça
s'ouvre et par là parce que léman est
tellement fort qu'il ya pas de jeu en
fait quand on le touche et du coup la
pièce on la met dedans mais peut-être ça
c'est juste pour le transport ou pour
nous bright fait que je sais pas du tout
moi en fait que quand je les ai reçus il
n'y avait pas de pièces du tout il est
juste marquer dans la notice qui fait
les met une pièce dans la tirelire et
réussir à la sortir d'où ma blague de
départ de durval à sortir sera très
compliqué c'est que le but était de 1
watt
stylé deux casse-tête un peu plus simple
sur l'insoluble ils sont en rupture je
ne sais pas s'ils en auront d'autres
vous aurez le lien dans la description
bravo en tout cas aux créateurs jules et
à jean-claude sont les créateurs de ces
deux beaux objets là tu es très cool
dites moi ce que vous en avez pensé dans
les commentaires ces deux casse-tête
seront à gagner sur mon instagram là en
ce moment je vous dis c'est là et je ne
fais pas des postes exprès pour en faire
gagner 1 en fait j'en ai un peu trop la
faire gagner donc je vais faire un poste
avec mass casse tête à gagner voilà ce
sera fait très prochainement peut-être y
en aurait déjà fait 1 entre temps je
fais souvent des gros concours en fait
sur mon instagram avec toutes les choses
qu'on a et c'est donc n'hésitez pas à me
suivre c'est celui-là vous donne rendez
vous très bientôt pour une prochaine
vidéo ici je vous mets deux autres casse
tête 1 c'est la tesla box et l'autre
c'est une grosse voix dangereuse mais
incroyable à la base il faut être 6 pour
la faire et je me tente de la faire tout
seul tout seul tout seul merci encore
une fois d'avoir regardé la vidéo merci
à monster.fr de nous avoir soutenus dans
la création de contenu avec ce
partenariat en début de programme prenez
soin de vous à très bientôt ciao